Revisore: Michelangelo Bardella
(Musica)
Mi chiamo Anastasia Massone,
in arte “Sparagn’ e Cumbarisc“.
Non so quanti abruzzesi ci sono qui.
Possiamo fare per alzata di mano, visto
che non ho ancora usato questa modalità.
Ok, grazie.
“Sparagn’ e Cumbarisc” vuol dire
“risparmia e fai bella figura”.
Nel senso che non bisogna spendere
eccessivamente tanto per apparire.
E questo è il motto del mio brand
o della mia pagina.
Ma tornando a “Sparagn’ e Cumbarisc”,
non è solo una questione di apparire,
ma anche di tornare ad apprezzare
le cose semplici della vita,
tipo andare nei paesi,
nei borghi ormai dimenticati
e visitare luoghi
che ormai sono stati abbandonati.
Quindi io ho deciso di rimanere in Abruzzo
anche per questo motivo,
perché un sacco di persone
mi dicevano sempre:
“Ma che ci fai ancora qui, a Vasto?”
“Perché non vieni con me a Milano
a lavorare, a cercare lavoro?”
Io dicevo: “No, io resto a Vasto
perché voglio provare a rimanere qui
e crearmi qualcosa di mio.”
E per questo mi sono buttata,
creando una maglietta simpatica
che parla di un cibo tipico abruzzese.
Non so se avete mai mangiato
le “pallotte cacio e ova”.
Esatto.
Quindi è nato tutto per scherzo.
Dalle “pallotte cacio e ova”
ho iniziato a frequentare...
Grazie a loro ho iniziato a frequentare
tantissime sagre ed eventi,
conoscendo un sacco di ragazzi
che mi hanno fatto apprezzare
ancora di più la mia regione
e mi hanno dato tantissimi stimoli
a continuare il mio lavoro.
In questi paesi, ho conosciuto anche
tantissime signore
che mi hanno fatto delle domande assurde.
Un giorno ero finita a Bomba,
e al posto di andare al lago ho detto:
”Ma dai, andiamo in paese a vedere
com’è il vicolo, le storie, le strade.”
In quel momento stavano suonando
tantissime campane.
Si affaccia una signora,
ci guarda e ci dice:
“Ma chi è morto?”
E noi: “Oh Dio, signora scusi,
non siamo del posto,
non lo sappiamo chi è morto.”
“Ah, e che ci fate qui, vi siete persi?
Qui non ci viene mai nessuno.”
“Questo paese ormai è all’abbandono.
Che ci fate qua, ragazzi?”
Ho detto: “Noi stiamo provando a visitare
posti per farli conoscere a ragazzi che,
come noi stanno nutrendo
le nostre stesse passioni.
In quel momento,
capii anche il motivo
per cui stavo rimanendo in Abruzzo,
perché la mia missione,
oltre a far conoscere la regione,
e a far apprezzare
le piccole cose della vita,
era far conoscere
un altro significato del FOMO.
Non so se conoscete
questo termine che in inglese...
lo dirò tradotto in italiano
perché il mio inglese è super maccheronico
ma è la paura di essere
tagliati dal momento,
che ogni persona ha paura
di essere tagliato dalle fasce sociali,
sta sempre con il cellulare in mano
a controllare i social,
tipo: “Oddio, che cosa è successo
qui a questa festa?”,
controlliamo tutte le storie
Instagram e Facebook.
Grazie sempre ai banchetti,
ho avuto il modo di visitare paesi,
abbandonati come ho già detto,
ma anche luoghi terremotati
che ormai sono proprio lasciati andare
e ho incontrato
dei signori che mi guardavano.
Era un festival, mi guardavano e dicevano:
“Ma che ci fanno così tanti ragazzi qui?”
“Ma è proprio bello vedere questi giovani
che stanno riempiendo
i vicoli della strada.”
Mi faceva l’interrogatorio dicendomi:
“Ma come mai da queste parti?”
“Perché gli organizzatori non organizzano
questi eventi nelle grandi città?”
Il mio brand,
oltre a far conoscere il territorio,
vuole far tornare di moda il dialetto
tra i giovani, ma non in senso...
Come posso dire...
Ormai è un linguaggio dimenticato.
I giovani quando vengono
in negozio da me mi chiedono:
“Ma cosa vuol dire questa parola?”
“Cosa vuol dire questa frase?”
Io ci rimango e dico: “Ma come,
non sai cosa vuol dire questo?”
“Eh, a casa mia
non si parla più il dialetto.”
Ho detto: “Beata te!
Io quando ero piccola non capivo niente.”
Perché comunque a Vasto
ci sono due tipi di dialetto.
C’è “Lu Uàštareul”,
che è il linguaggio più antico
che parlano i nonni dei nonni
e poi c’è il Vastese che è
il linguaggio che parliamo noi,
che è un italiano un po’ dialettizzato,
ma nulla di che,
che non ha niente a che fare.
Quindi sto anche cercano di portare
oltre al dialetto,
sto cercando di far tornare di moda,
“in auge”, come si dice,
le tradizioni,
un po’ di folklore popolare.
Io volevo chiudere con una citazione
de “La guerra degli Antò“,
non so se avete mai visto il film.
La frase era:
“Ci vuole coraggio ad andare
a vivere ad Amsterdam,
ma ci vuole coraggio
anche a rimanere a Montesilvano.”
Ed è vero, è una frase che ho detto:
“Faccio girare tutta la conversazione
su questa frase.”
Però, non parlando tanto ho anche problemi
ad associare i dialoghi ai discorsi.
Va bene? Posso scappare adesso?
Grazie, grazie mille davvero.